avec nous la docteure cesser le tremblay
bonsoir docteur tremblay en soi mais se
voit est-ce qu'on va connaître toutes
les lettres grecques comme ça une après
les ont pas ce que pour ceux qui se
posent la question c'est quoi au micro
on ratait c'est une lettre grecque l'eau
ahmed qui désigne les variants avec une
nouvelle lettre grecque à chaque fois
cette delta on a passé par-dessus nuées
et qui met pour arriver à au micro
est-ce que ce variant alors je vous
posais des questions très précises dans
une seconde mais de façon générale est
ce que c'est une surprise que ça vous
inquiète tous c'est pas la nature de la
bête de se transformer
c'est pas une surprise et ça m'inquiète
donc oui c'est dans la nature de la bête
de se transformer on s'attend plus il va
y avoir de la transmission communautaire
et ce n'est partout dans le monde que ce
soit en europe ou aux états unis en
afrique il va ya voir l'émergence de
nouveaux variants et quentin valiant
émergent habituellement celui qui gagne
la partie c'est celui qui est le plus
capable de se transmettre donc il est
plus contagieux ça semble être le cas
avec au micro mais on connaît encore
très peu sur ses caractéristiques sur 16
bis rue danse et puis sur cette façon
d'échapper au système ou tel nom bon ben
justement géo poser une question à la
fois est ce que on sait la première
question s'il est plus contagieux est-ce
que ça c'est on le sait ou pas lundi
17h04
7h04 on n'est pas certaine mais on pense
que des indices qui nous dit qu'il est
contagieux parce que un peu de temps en
afrique du sud il a remplacé le delta de
tous les cas qui sont arrivés dans cette
province de gauteng qui la province
autour de johannesburg alors il ya de
l'art est assez contagieux puis on voit
là que ça se propage un petit peu
partout mais c'est pas encore établies
parce que ça nous prend des plus grand
dénominateur pour établir son île le
remplacer on dit parlant de son ca
contagion il le remplacer très
rapidement le delta l'eia c'est lui qui
a pris la place il y à peu près partout
maintenant
il oui il l'a remplacé le delta en
afrique du sud
mais les cas quand on dit qu'il ya des
corps partout ce sont la majorité des
cas les cas importés donc des gens qui
avaient voyagé en afrique et qui lors on
ne les a détectés à l'arrivée dans leur
pays il n'y a pas encore de transmission
soutenue communautaire bon ces pays là
mais tout ça peut changer d'une heure à
l'autre impie domaine vous dire
exactement contraire et il fait la vraie
question qu'on se pose deuxième question
est il plus virulents donc plus
dangereux
présentement ne pas d'indication que
c'est le cas on ne sait pas ça va
prendre plus grand nombre d'infections
pour pouvoir calculer les proportions de
gens qui se rendent à l'hôpital suite à
une infection on ne sait pas les cas qui
sont survenus l'endroit où liz le plus
étudié c'est en afrique du sud y'avait
potes comme d'évidence qu'il était plus
virulent mais c'est trop tôt pour le
dire d'accord plus résistants aux
vaccins ça c'est évidemment si jamais il
était plus virulent 20 tueur que les
vaccins sur oeufs soit efficace en fait
c'est la grande inquiétude le le patron
de mutation qui est observé chez ce
bulletin là
une trentaine de mutation qui dans la
protéine lot de l' enveloppe qui se
lient à nos cellules et permis ces
mutations l'oeil des mutations qu'on
retrouvait dans le var hier bête qui lui
avait une baisse de sensibilité aux
vaccins alors on ne sait pas si c'est
une nouvelle mutation là il y en eu plus
que dans les autres variant ça peut
conférer soit une plus grande résistance
aux vaccins ou peut-être aucune
résistance aux accès qu on ne sait pas
c'est pour ça que les études sont faites
en laboratoire présentement ça prend
quand même quelques temps pour faire les
études parce qu'il faut fabriquer des
des mini virus là pour pouvoir faire les
essais les tests de laboratoire
alors d'ici deux semaines on devrait
savoir ce bon donc d'ici deux semaines
on va être fixé on devrait être fixé sur
ce qu'on appelle la la capacité d or du
corps qu'on a pris le bébé des gens qui
ont fait la maladie et les handicaps
qu'on a prélevé chez des gens qui ont
été doublés vacciner on teste le virus
contre c'est andy car là et on voit si
les handicaps réussissent à le
neutraliser ce sont les études que l'on
fait présentement bon alors d'où votre
inquiétude mais pas de panique pour
l'instant surveille la virulence et ici
les vaccins sont encore efficaces est ce
que ça nous amène pas en terminant
docteur tran bien l'autre question de la
vaccination mais pour tous les pays de
la planète si on garde beaucoup de pays
du sud n'ont vacciné que je fais pas
nécessairement référence à l'afrique du
sud où il ya un taux plus élevé mais où
continent africain continent sud
américain en inde etc
si encore de grandes grandes poches de
l'humanité non vaccinés est ce qu'on
n'est pas pris à ce que la roue tourne
continuellement tout est fait
c'est une pandémie c'est global c'est pô
juste dans un pays avant la mesure où on
laisse le virus se répliquer que ce soit
en europe parce que quand même des pays
d'europe lyon et toute vaccination plus
faible qu'en afrique soit dit en passant
alors il faut faire un effort
supplémentaire pour vacciner l'ensemble
des citoyens de la planète et ça ça
passe par deux jours d'une pas rendre
les vaccins accessible mais je dirais
que c'est moins sûr le problème
présentement parce qu'on en eau des
vaccins on en les états unis en fabrique
il y en a tellement qui sait leur parler
d'abord que positive alors il donne
alors la difficulté la plus importante
c'est des pays à ressources limitées la
capacité de vacciner donc d'aller vite
donné ces doses le aux patients et puis
et les infrastructures de santé temps
très faible dans plusieurs pays sur leur
capacité de mener une campagne de
vaccination massive qui est un des plus
grands défis je dirais présent bon mais
que l'on fasse tous nos efforts pour les
appuyer dans donc tout le monde ne sera
pas
geri entropa bieri globalement c'est un
peu solide et on y revient dr tremblay
le noël lorsque votre intuition vous dit
quoi sur les rassemblements et parce que
l'on peut pas demander aux gens de
reculer chez nous quand même
mon intuition me dit la même chose
qu'elle me disait avant au micro c'est à
dire qu'il ya une semaine je vous
parlais je parlais au public puis je
disais soyons prudents soyons vigilants
parce que regardons les cas les
commandes on a libéralisé certaine
mesure on s'attendait à voir les
communautés et si ce qui se passe
maintenant on n'a pas encore vu une
augmentation des hospitalisations mais
faut se donner quelques semaines avant
de voir ce onze ils ont inventé un petit
peu depuis alors moi je me dis va
falloir rester prudent pendant le temps
des fêtes ce sera pas le temps de faire
des grands rassemblements de famille et
si au micron nous envahi alors d'autant
plus va falloir être encore plus crue
dans sa salle mais pas très très gros
mais non exhaustive au jeu côté lumineux
de la proposition mais quand même
rassemblement mes posts pas si groupe à
45 et puis je vous rappelle que le
masque le lavage des nez et la
distanciation ça marche contre tous les
virus qui s'appelle au micron deltort
l'influenza ou la gastro intérêts alors
ça reste des très bonnes précautions qui
nous protège de toute sorte de chose qui
pourrait arriver comme prévoir dr cécile
tremble on va se parler en tout cas
c'est sûr d'ici deux semaines quand tu
n'auras on en saura un peu plus sur au
micro merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh